[Music]
Meghan Markle breaks her silence
following Queen Elizabeth's death
explaining it's been a complicated time
I think the pictures that we saw are of
family members arriving at Balmoral
really said it all this is a family and
in mourning now and um of course the
queen was a mother a grandmother and a
great grandmother I think it is quite
telling that Prince Harry traveled solo
to Balmoral he took we understand a
flight on his own and he was not
accompanied by The Duchess of Sussex I
think that is deeply significant that
Megan was not invited to join the family
by the Queen's bedside The Duchess of
Sussex opens up for the first time about
the death of her husband Prince Harry's
late grandma in a new cover story for
variety the mom of two joined Harry for
several of the official official events
including the state funeral which took
place on September 19th at Westminster
Abbey in London and ever since Megan
says there's been an outpouring of love
and support quote I'm really grateful
that I was able to be with my husband to
support him especially during that time
but she describes the events following
the Queen's death as a complicated time
it's understood that the family Wanted
Prince Harry to be there even though he
was unable to get to Balmoral in time to
see his grandmother
um but Megan The Duchess of Sussex was
not we understand invited to join the
family and despite all that Megan says
Harry has a particularly sweet
perspective on his grandmother's death
quote my husband ever The Optimist said
now she's reunited with her husband the
Queen's husband Prince Philip died last
year at the age of 99. it is in Windsor
where she will be in entered along with
the late Duke of Edinburgh her husband
Prince Philip the former actress goes on
to call the Queen a shining example of
female leadership noting that she feels
deep gratitude for the time she was able
to spend with the Monarch quote I've
reflected on that first official
engagement that I had with her how
special that felt I feel fortunate and I
continue to be proud to have had a nice
warmth with the matriarch of the family
as for how she and Harry are moving
forward without hrh Meg says their focus
is on the future in big moments in life
you get a lot of perspective it makes
you wonder what you want to focus your
energy on right now we feel energized
and excited about all of the things
we've been building toward
foreign